understanding obesity the words
overweight and obesity mean a person's
body weight is higher than what is
considered healthy for their height in
general people can become overweight or
obese due to an imbalance of energy
energy in comes from calories in the
food you eat energy out is the amount of
calories your body burns during physical
activity over time if your energy in is
less than your energy out you will lose
weight if your energy in is about the
same as your energy out your weight will
stay the same if your energy in is
greater than your energy out you will
gain weight
risks for becoming obese include an
inactive lifestyle lack of access to
places to exercise lack of access to
healthy food a diet rich in high-calorie
fatty and sugary foods meals with
oversized food portions having a family
history of being overweight or obese
diseases such as hypothyroidism and
polycystic ovary syndrome side effects
from some medications lack of sleep
emotions that can make you want to eat
more and advertisements for high-calorie
unhealthy food and drinks obesity raises
your risk of developing health problems
such as type 2 diabetes high blood
pressure high cholesterol heart disease
stroke and certain cancers if you have
questions about obesity talk to your
health care provider